باشا وجبل في مصر حول فتوى تحضر مشاهده
المباريات البرازيل واثقه من عوده نيمار
لقياده السامبا نحو لقب سادس يتلقى
تهديدات بعد اتهامه باهانه العلم المكسيكي
هذه الاخبار وغير ها نقولها لكم قناه
العربيه فعلا
نبدا من مصر حيث اثار مشاهده المباريات
باعتبارها اهدارا للوقت والمال اثرت جدلا
واسعا في البلاد فيما ردت دار الافتاء
مؤكده ان مشاهده المباريات امر مباح
ومشروع وكان رئيس مجلس شيوخ حزب النور
السلفي يونس مخيون اطلق الفتوى عبر صفحته
على مواقع التواصل قائلا فيها ان اللاعب
كره القدم هو اهدار الوقت والعمره وفيها
قلب للموازين وخلط للمفاهيم للناس يعني
حتى تعبيره فيما او تحدث دار الافتاء ان
كره القدم
وانما مفيده وتسهم في التعريف على
الثقافات الاخرى على حديقه قولها
في اخبار المونديال ايضا بدا البرازيليون
وواثقين من استعاده خدمات نجمهم نيمار
لمساعدتهم بالفوز بكاس العالم للمره
السادسه بعد ما حامت الشقوق حول امكانيه
تعافه من الاصابه بكحله الايمن زميلنا
نيمار في نادي باريس سان جيرمان المدافع
ماركينيوس قال ان نيمار يمضي ايامه
بالخضوع للعلاج الطبيعي المكثف منذ تعرضه
للاصابه بهدف التعافي في اقرب وقت ممكن
فيما توقع مدرب البرازيل بان المنتخب
يمكنه الاعتماد على نيمار مجددا دون ذكر
اي تفاصيل اخرى
بعد ما اتهامه باهانتي علمي بلاده وجه
الملاكم المكسيكيه العالمي كانيلو البرز
تحذيرا الى لاعب المنتخب الارجنتيني
ليونيل ميسي بسبب اللقطه انتشرت انتشارا
واسعا بعد مباراه البلديه
المتداول اظهر ميسي وهو يقوم بازاحه قميص
منتخب المكسيك المرميه على الارض بقدم لي
اثناء محاولته لخلع حذائه داخل غرفه تغيير
الملابس بعد اللقاء فيما قال الملاكم
المكسيكي على تويتر مخاطبا ميسي مثل ما
احترم انا الارجنتين عليه احترام المكسيك
مضيفا يجب ان يصلي كي لا اجده
بدي اخبار المونديال ايضا لفتت صور نجم
منتخب المغرب اشرف حكيمي مع والدته
الانظار والاعشاب من قبل الجماهير وارواد
مواقع التواصل وذلك بعد فوز اسود الاطلس
على بلجيكا بهدفين الدوري مقابل لاعب
باريس سان جيرمان نشر الصور عبر حسابه
الخاص في تويتر معلقا بالقول احبك امي
لتنهال عليه تعليقات المديح والتقدير حتى
ان البعض اطلق على هذه الصوره لقب ايقونه
بر الوالدين فيما علق حساب الفيفا المخصص
لكاس العالم على الصوره بالقول حكيمي
ووالدته كان نجميل اليوم امام عدسه
المصورين
[موسيقى]
وفي خبرينا الاخير حكمت محكمه امن الدوله
في جزر القمر على الرئيس السابق للبلاد
احمد عبد الله سامي بالسجن مدى الحياه
بتهمه الخيانه العظمى وكالات فرانسبريس
اوضحت ان ساندي ظهر لفتره وجيزه في اليوم
الاول من محاكمتها الاسبوع الماضي وندد
باجراء يعتبره غير عاجل ثم تغيب عن بقيه
الجلسات مشيره الى انه متهم بالتورط في
فضيحه برنامج المواطنه الاقتصاديه اذ اصدر
قانونا في العام 2008 يتيح بيع جوازات
السفر بسعر مرتفع لمن يسعون للحصول على
الجنسيه